bonsoir le journal de la rédaction sur
tv fil 78 comme chaque soir du lundi au
vendredi dès 18h en direct et voici les
titres de ce mardi 27 janvier le groupe
d'aéronautique et de défense de sécurité
safran s'installe dans les communes de
château fort et de magny les hameaux les
nouveaux locaux inaugurés aujourd'hui
les socialistes en campagne les
départementales se déroule dans deux
mois comment faire venir les électeurs
aux urnes
une invitée sandrine grand grande
première secrétaire fédérale du ps dans
les yvelines les championnats du monde
de cyclisme approche la liste des
coureurs français tout juste dévoilé les
noms et les premières réactions à suivre
tout à l'heure mais pour débuter ce
journal c'est et hier lundi les travaux
du premier chantier d'insertion du
département des yvelines inauguré le
chantier s'est déroulé au square louis
pergaud attrape le groupe immobilier 3f
souhaitait améliorer les parties
communes de certains immeubles
il s'est engagé à le faire avec l'aide
d'une association bleus oxygène
développement le chantier a duré un nom
une année qui a permis à l'association
de remettre dix personnes sur le chemin
de l'emploi écouté le directeur de
l'association bleu oxygène jérôme à
tibre on a été contacté par le bailleur
i3f pour participer à la réhabilitation
d'une partie des cages d'escaliers dieu
du patrimoine square pergaud attrapé
donc on a utilisé cette situation de
chantier pour permettre aux salariés en
insertion développer des compétences
dans les métiers du second oeuvre et
plus particulièrement de la peinture et
à la suite du chantier qui s'est étalée
sur une période d'un an de préparer le
titre professionnel peintre en bâtiment
et si l'on doit faire un petit bilan on
en est tout à fait satisfait le groupe
international de haute technologie
safran a donc choisi de regrouper toutes
ces équipes innovation et recherche sur
un seul et même site situé à château
fort et à magny les hameaux le choix
elle n'est pas anodin il permettra de
renforcer la symbiose avec le plateau de
saclay le premier pôle technologique de
france au coeur de l'opération d'intérêt
national paris-saclay yolaine thorez
patrick jacques de dixmude ont assisté à
l'inauguration du site
mardi matin ce matin peu après 11 heures
geneviève fioraso fait son arrivée sur
ce nouveau site de paris saclay et pas
des moindres il s'agit en effet de
s'affronter que le nouveau centre de
recherche et technologie du groupe
safran en compagnie du pdg et du
directeur du centre
la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche a inauguré le site l'ensemble
des industries françaises
suite au discours place à la visite
guidée du site un site qui appartenait à
un opérateur de télécoms il ya encore
plus de cinq ans et qui a ensuite été
fermé pendant plusieurs années
aujourd'hui il renaît enfin mille
personnes y travaillent déjà
elle devrait être 1500 fin 2016 donc
s'affronter l'aéronautique ont fait le
système pour la défense et puis on fait
aussi des systèmes pour la sécurité donc
dans ce centre on va travailler sur
l'ensemble des technologies qui servent
à tous ses métiers
l'implantation du nouveau site sur le
territoire de paris saclay n'est pas dû
au hasard mais bel et bien choisi pour
des critères stratégiques et bien précis
on a besoin d'avoir à proximité
ce qu'on appelle un cluster
d'universités de centres de recherche de
collègues de l'industrie qui ont aussi
leurs centres de recherche donc il ya
vraiment on va être dans le pôle
scientifique et de recherche
industrielle le plus important en france
et à un pôle de rayonnement mondial donc
c'est ça qu'on cherchait ici en fait on
est persuadé que l'innovation nécessite
qu'on s'ouvre sur l'extérieur une
ouverture sur l'extérieur félicité par
la secrétaire d'état qui en profite
aussi pour rappeler l'importance de
l'innovation en matière d'emploi et de
compétitivité
safran a embauché au cours de ces quatre
dernières années
onze villes salariés dont 5000 en france
ça montre que l'innovation c'est bien le
levier essentiel pour faire croître les
entreprises et rendre plus compétitive
en france met immédiatement à l'export
et crée des emplois
l'investissement global pour ce nouveau
site représente près de 60 millions
d'euros et s'élèvera à plus de 80
millions d'euros d'ici 2018
l'ump veut réaliser le grand chelem lors
des élections la départementale dans les
yvelines
l'actuel président pierre bédier en
annonçant vouloir l'emporter dans les 21
cantons a donc décidé de mettre la
pression sur ses adversaires et
notamment le parti socialiste bonsoir
sandrine gambas la première fédéral du
ps dans le département des yvelines est
ce que vous sentez aujourd'hui une
pression plus ou moins fortes sur vos
épaules avec ce scrutin
ram département pression non on est
parti dans une campagne électorale on en
a vu d'autres de campagne c'est vrai que
le terrain des yvelines est un peu
particulier mais on se met en ordre de
marche est content de de porter nos
valeurs face à une droite départementale
qui parfois oublient les siennes
l'objectif 22 29 mars pour ce scrutin
l'objectif c'est de conserver les neuf
conseillers que vous avez conseiller ps
souhaite c'est compliqué d'avoir des
chiffres parce qu'il faut expliquer un
téléspectateur on change de deux cantons
ont donc on passe de 39 à 21 avec un
grand avantage du nouveau scrutin c'est
qu'on aura une assemblée paritaire
lorsqu'il ya des vidéos un homme une
femme élue à chaque fois donc on espère
faire rentrer évidemment le plus
d'hommes et de femmes de gauche quand
cette assemblée mais pour l'instant on
est sur une assemblée qui est quand même
une anomalie total il ya très très peu
de femmes et l'exécutif
aujourd'hui c'est que des hommes n'a pas
une vice-présidente ce qui existe
ailleurs ailleurs dans aucune
collectivité donc c'est bien que ce mode
scrutin était bon ça ça permettra
d'avancer mais sur le sur le patron au
parti socialiste sur les résultats que
vous pouvez attendre
on espère bien sûr gardez le
les conseillers on a un certain nombre
de conseillers sortants qui se
représentent donc on espère bien sûr
qu'ils seront dans la nouvelle assemblée
et puis et puis par exemple un canton
qu'on va regarder de très près avec
est-ce que la campagne qui va mener
françoise descamps crosnier sur le
mantois face avec un bélier aussi sa
pierre bédier y aura également cyril
vote pour le front national qui sera qui
sera candidat il y aura effectivement un
enjeu assez assez fort là-bas vous avez
présenté vos différents candidats en
tout cas pas la totalité mais une grande
partie
vous serez d'ailleurs vous même
candidate une candidate sur le canton de
montigny le bretonneux guyancourt alors
pourquoi ce canton alors que maintenant
vous êtes élu à trappes dans la majorité
municipale jeudi pourquoi revenir à
montigny-le-bretonneux parce que vous
avez siégé pendant un temps au conseil
municipal sur la commune dans
l'opposition et a fait pour moi c'est
tout ça c'est le même territoire c'est
theater de 50 ans les limites ça vous
demandez aux gens quelles sont les
limites de leur canton à mon avis ils en
ont aucune idée s'est pas vraiment ce
qui est important on élit une assemblée
départementale c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
en tête
donc pour moi c'est naturel d'aller là
où on me demande d'aller aussi c'était
une demande de françois ii signé et en
tant que responsable des convalescents
dans un sursaut cas et comme responsable
politique départemental ça me paraissait
logique de mouiller la chemise et puis
de l'accompagner dans cette dans cette
nouvelle bataille politique sans
quasiment rien en jeu puisqu'on parle de
la candidature en tout cas pour
l'instant c'est qu'une rumeur mais la
candidature qui devrait être annoncée
est de michel logis le président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et qui est
également maire de montigny le
bretonneux qui pourraient se présenter
un enjeu particulier on se présente pas
contre des gens on se présente pour
défendre un programme donc
bush pas qui sera candidat si c'est lui
ou quelqu'un d'autre peut importe ce
qu'il faut c'est que l'on puisse être
audible pour les électeurs et qu'ils
puissent comprendre qu'on va porter leur
message dans une assemblée
départementale qui malheureusement est
quand même très très majoritairement à
droite donc 580 voix aurait un goût
particulier oui c'est moi en face au
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin
suite aux élections c'est pas sur ce
mode là que non je l'idée c'est
pour le coup par rapport à ce que vous
disiez par rapport à permet d'y et qui
veut faire entre guillemets le grand
chelem
aucun sens pour moi si à un moment donné
on est dans une république on a besoin
d'une opposition d'une majorité on peut
pas avoir un problème un programme
politique dont l'objectif est
l'éradication de l'opposition enfin
c'est quand on est démocrate ça n'a pas
de sens
donc on espère vraiment en tout cas sur
le territoire de 50 à garder le canton
de trappes avec jany mari qui est
sortante et le canto de françois ii
signé sur lesquels je me présente van
uhm arrive justement sur le canton de
trappes qui sera reconduite sinon oui
oui alors là on travaille parce que
c'est aussi là aussi important qu'on
fasse le rassemblement de l'ensemble des
forces de gauche en tout cas la majorité
des forces de gauche et donc on y
travaille et je suis plutôt optimiste ce
serait éventuellement avec un binôme
avec à l'arrachage le maire de la
verrière sa fille pour être partant vous
donnera l'information ça peut faire
partie des possibilités en tout cas on
travaille à ce genre de proposition donc
vous souhaitez faire l'alliance ont sans
doute aussi c'est pour contrer forcément
la droite puisque - galles candidatures
à gauche plus ces fraudes profitable
pour la candidature d'union pour pouvoir
l'emporter
et puisque ce serait ce sera ça c'est
officiel jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt qui se présentera sur ce
canton pour autant dans certains cantons
il n'y a pas d'alliance avec la gauche
le parti socialiste par seul on n'avait
pas réussi à fédérer autour de vous nous
on continue par la gauche anti austérité
à 100 sur l'école aussi par l oms
continue de tendre la main à l'ensemble
des partenaires on vient de conclure
l'accord avec le prg et génération
écologie qui nous soutiendrons dans la
plupart des cantons du département au
jeu le parti europe ecologie les verts
au cas par cas j'espère qu'on arrivera à
faire à faire des alliances moi j'en
appelle à la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des responsables politiques
de gauche parce que il ya des enjeux qui
dépassent aussi l'histoire de nos
formations
c'est des enjeux pour la gauche
notamment face à une droite qui n'est
pas toujours république a dans certains
endroits et face à une droite qui est le
front national qui aujourd'hui est en
train de gagner du terrain et c'est
notre responsabilité d'être unie face à
ça sur un dernier quand on peut être
pour évoquer ce cas là celui où se
présentera celui de maurepas où se
présentera le sortant ismaël
c'est un peu particulier parce que ce
canton a été redécoupée il fait partie
de ceux qui ont été à traire découpé et
s'étend maintenant jusqu'en vallée de
chevreuse et du coup il y aura deux
sortants puisque ils vendent mal pour la
droite qui avait été élu sur ce secteur
sera lui aussi candidat est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils se mêlent à vannes est en
position pour le conserver ce canton
même s'il a été redécoupée sachant que
lors de sa victoire en 2008 c'était
particulier y avait deux candidatures
abl il a fait ce choix parce qu'ils
étaient présentes à maurepas il pouvait
finalement son canton l'ancien canton
est éclatée en de ils pouvaient soit se
présenter sur le canton de trappes et
l'encours soit sur celui de maurepas il
a fait le choix en conscience de se
présenter là il sait que c'est pas le le
choix le plus facile qu'il a fait mais
moi je salue son courage politique et
puis c'est à dire que on a des gens de
conviction qui porte des idées plus que
des ambitions personnelles donc il va il
va faire une campagne avec christine
mercier qui est première adjointe de
bertrand lyon à manier les mots je sais
qu'ils ont déjà commencé qui vont faire
une belle campagne
nous allons continuer à parler des
départementales avec vous vous allez
nous expliquer comment va se dérouler la
campagne
auparavant ce micro trottoir elle les
élections départementales est ce que
c'est un scrutin qui vous intéresse ou
non vos réponses je vous avoue que nous
pas vraiment peut-être devant le manque
de visibilité médiatique et peut-être
que les enjeux aussi sont peut-être pas
assez clairement exposé ce genre de
choses ouais je commence à l'étagé
m'enfin à nos enfants nos petits enfants
n'est intéressé quand même par ce qui se
passe on alors à deux votes il faut
l'utiliser
moi je suis pas drôle de gens encore
mais c'est quand même très important
c'est quand même notre premier
interlocuteur le département donc c'est
une chose importante il faut donner
notre avis parce que sinon si on n'y
voit pas ben c'est pas la peine après
qu'on se plaigne pas parce que c'est le
devoir déjà parce qu'on a le droit à la
parole déjà j'ai toujours voté pour des
minorités de type extrême gauche le
pouvoir on ne prendra pas révolution et
par par la force donc les élections sont
un piège à cons ça au moins au moins cet
éclair pour ce saint quentinois sur son
sa vision sur les élections
au delà de ça le scrutin départemental
intéresse finalement assez peu comme
vous allez faire campagne c'est quand on
est surtout en zone urbaine c'est
particulier souvent les
la relation au conseil général
maintenant ça sera le conseil
départemental est différente en zone
rurale ce qui explique d'ailleurs le
projet du gouvernement de supprimer à
terme le département
en revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que les
missions qui sont aujourd'hui celles du
département elles seront bien assumée
par une collectivité donc de toutes
façons il faut avoir des projets et d
une vision sur ce que doit être l'action
sociale sur ce que doit être par exemple
la gestion des collèges qui enfin quels
que soient ensuite la collectivité qui
sont en charge de qui récupérera ses
compétences là donc nous c'est plutôt
dense sur le long terme qu'on travaille
aussi avec une vision sur comment on
assume ses compétences qui sont pour
l'instant celle du département et qui à
terme sont soit intercos soit à la
région est en soi une campagne plutôt
active son terrain dès à présent sur
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est lent
c'est d'abord une campagne très
politique dans le contexte actuel moi je
veux vous parler par exemple de l'union
nationale etc
il faudrait pas confondre union
nationale et dépolitisation
on peut être dans une logique de se
retrouver sur des sujets par contre
l'intérêt général est en jeu hier
j'étais au stif au quotidien aux côtés
de michèle losier pour défendre des
projets de territoire concernant les
transports
il n'y avait pas de divergence par
contre sur des visions que l'on a sur
d'autres projets c'était le cas sur
l'intercommunalité terrain il faut dire
notre différence il faut dire ce que ce
qu'est un projet de gauche
par rapport à un projet de droite et ça
c'est juste la démocratie donc il faut
pas avoir peur de ça juste une dernière
question qui porta à présent sur
l'avenir peut-être de la fédération aux
socialistes écoutez à ce propos elle la
sénatrice l'ancienne ministre catherine
tasca
nous avons une organisation qui
fonctionne beaucoup sur la base
municipale nos sections sont calqués sur
les municipalités sur les communes il
est vraiment important de travailler
dans un cadre plus large que le seul
cadre des communes
seul cadre municipal donc il s'agit tout
simplement dans la proximité des des
communes que les sections se rassemble
elles auront une assise plus large
ça veut dire une caisse de résonance
plus large une capacité aussi à attirer
de nouveaux militants qu'ils soient ou
non adhérents
vous êtes plutôt d'accord ce qui vient
d'être dit oui évidemment sauf que en
fait on peut pas mélanger toutes les
sections il ya des sections dans des
grandes villes qui sont déjà très
nombreuses il ya des petites sections
qui ont déjà l'habitude en fait de trail
en intersection donc on fait déjà ce
travail de rapprochement de manière
assez assez générales dès qu'on est sur
des sujets de fond quand on a donc fait
venir des personnes extérieures le cadre
naturel c'est les intersections donc
c'est là la démarche qui est déjà qui
est déjà en cours et puis dernier aspect
qui est évoqué par catherine tasca ce
qui est très important c'est l'ouverture
je pense qu'il faut vraiment que si on
veut que les parties puissent jouer leur
rôle démocratique il faut montrer que ce
qui s'y passe à l'intérieur c'est
intéressant c'est du débat c'est la
convivialité et pour ça il faut ouvrir
les portes et cette réflexion autour de
la réorganisation du parti socialiste
s'engage et elle est déjà engagée
même après les élections elle est alors
comment ces permanents on sait quelque
chose qui qui est en discussion et des
évolutions qui sont assez permanente
après il y aura le moment du congrès où
ces éléments seront débattues et où les
militants auront à trancher aussi sur
ces aspects là juste une question qui
concerne les élections régionales parce
que l'on parle du scrutin départemental
et l'éventuelle réorganisation le
scrutin régional
vous êtes conseillère régionale sortante
rosetti aux côtés de jean paul huchon
une nouvelle candidature de jean paul
huchon
vous êtes favorable c'est ça fait partie
des sujets que pour l'instant on a mis
de côté parce que ça va ça polémique
non parce que c'est pas sa candidature
pour un quatrième mandat parce que non
c'est pas que sa candidature soit pause
pause polémique c'est qu'il peut y avoir
d'autres candidats et que on peut avoir
une primaire ou d'autres candidats
légitimes ont envie de se présenter
simplement quand vous demandez
aujourd'hui aux militants socialistes
quelle est leur préoccupation c'est
certainement pas ça c'est c'est d'être
sur l'organisation pour les élections
départementales d'ocala tourne à vive
allure
oui et je viendrai vous le dire dès que
le département passera pas cela et dès
que ce sera le temps je pense qu'il faut
pas mélanger les temps merci sans
vraiment le responsable dans les
yvelines du parti socialiste il était
question avec vous principalement des
élections départementales et si vous
avez manqué le début de cet entretien
voici ce reportage de catherine plateau
pour un petit rappel des candidats que
vous allez présenter dans le département
pour ces départementale ump veut frapper
fort pierre bédier le président sortant
du conseil général souhaite réaliser le
grand chelem
le parti socialiste ne l'entend pas
ainsi et mobilise dès à présent ses
troupes
le ps compte à ce jour neuf conseillers
généraux encartés socialistes ou
apparentés sur 39
on souhaite garder le maximum de cantons
que l'on détient et on en a pas
énormément dans le département c'est
aussi la survie du débat démocratique
dans le département qui est en jeu pour
ce scrutin ce n'est plus un candidat que
les électeurs doivent tenir mais un
binôme composé d'un homme et d'une femme
la prime est donnée au sortant
socialiste à commencer par le maire de
guyancourt et lui sur le canton de
montigny qui fera équipe avec la
première fédérale je porte un bilan le
travail de sept ans j'ai agi avec mes
collègues au sein du conseil général
pour que montigné pour guyancourt pour
saint quentin en yvelines
j'arrive avec eux une équipe est
évidemment des propositions pour
l'avenir
pour un département de justice sociale
et de solidarité les assure qu'elle a
bien besoin
on est dans ces élections qui sont
extrêmement politique où l'enjeu c'est
aussi l'enjeu de faire valoir la
pluralité des voix au sein du conseil
départemental et donc il m'a semblé
important de faire partie de ce combat
politique là en tant que responsable
socialiste du département
c'est pas quand c'est simple qu'il faut
y aller c'est aussi quand c'est
compliqué qu'il faut y aller jean
philippe mallet lui sera candidat sur le
canton de saint cyr l'école me sens pour
des valeurs à l'époque où là où la
france
avec les choses graves profondes nous
voulons nous battre pour ces valeurs qui
ont été portées par le peuple de france
face à une équipe ump usées le président
du conseil général du parti qui veut
faire le grand chelem il le dit partout
il a écrit voilà c'est à dire ils
souhaitent avoir une assemblée
départementale monocolore uniquement
représentée par des élus ump
il me semble que ce n'est pas une bonne
chose pour la démocratie ce n'est pas
une bonne chose
pas simplement pour la gauche mais pour
la démocratie et pour nos concitoyens
yvelinois donc voilà nous sommes des
militants de la république c'est de
porter des valeurs de solidarité de
fraternité et de dynamisme économique
avec une autre vision de l'économie que
celle qui est actuellement portée qui
est un peu passéistes le canton de
maurepas un canton très élargie qui
compte dorénavant des communes de la
vallée de chevreuse qui votent à droite
le challenge sera donc difficile à
relever pour le sortant socialiste élu à
maurepas toute élection est très
difficile il n'existe pas d'élections
qui est qui est très facile donc c'est à
nous de convaincre les habitants de ce
canton
on part avec des avantages quand même
qu'ils sont assez assez forts de notre
de notre point de vue on indiquait
complémentaires on a certes des
concurrents entre guillemets mais ce
n'est pas notre priorité
notre priorité c'est de donner une
réponse aux territoires aux habitants
aux termes de transport en terme de
solidarité on fait des réunions
intersection là qui vont débuter bientôt
et ensuite nos feront du porte-à-porte
on va aller sur les marchés etc c'est
vraiment une
une campagne que l'on veut proche des
habitants sur le canton de plaisir jean
michel gourdon élu depuis deux mandats
ne se représente pas redonnez aussi du
dynamisme au département dynamisme que
qui est nécessaire pour pour le
territoire des yvelines qui aujourd'hui
a réellement besoin d'une autre
politique et notamment sur les
compétences premières qui sont les
siennes en matière sociale que ce soit
aussi bien sûr la petite enfance que sur
les seniors que sur la politique du
handicap mais aussi évidemment sur tout
un politique du logement et de
l'environnement
nicholas hughes qui fera liste commune
avec frédéric evrard militante de
plaisir certains cantons n'ont pas
encore dévoilé leurs candidats c'est le
cas pour trappe qui compte dorénavant
les communes d'el en cours et de la
verrière jeanine marie conseillère
générale sortante divers gauche a
souhaité se représenter des rien n'est
encore tranché pour la première fédérale
a accompagné dans l'idée qu'il fallait
en tout cas le plus large rassemblement
de la gauche et rassemblement de la
gauche c'est un combat donc on continue
de le mener parce que ça nous paraît
essentiel sur ce canton le maire de la
verrière le communiste alain jaj n'a pas
caché qu'il se lancerait aussi un canton
modifié et élargi à droite le maire ump
d'elancourt a déjà annoncé qu'il sera
candidat
la bataille s'annonce rude les derniers
arbitrages devraient être rendus
rapidement la clôture des dépôts des
listes est fixée au 16 février pour ce
reportage donc consacrée aux élections
départementales cyclisme maintenant la
sélection française pour les
championnats du monde sur piste a été
dévoilé cet après midi par la fédération
les spectateurs du vélodrome de saint
quentin pour en voir en action
thomas boudât champion du monde 2014 de
l'homme
bryan coquard et lisbonne 0 l'endurance
dans les catégories de vitesse on
retrouve grégory baugé et michael
d'almeida lni montain françois pervis ce
dernier triple champion du monde l'année
dernière elle n'arrive pas dans les
meilleurs des conditions on les écoute
j'ai eu pas mal de pépins physiques je
suis tombé pas mal de fois malade cet
hiver ça a été j'ai été obligé
complètement d'arrêter l'entraînement
malheureusement j'ai pris beaucoup de
retard mais
et puis bon là dernièrement ma chute à
cali qui m'a fait encore prendre du
retard donc j'achète un peu tout en ce
moment là cet hiver mais je reste
confiant et puis
simplement je me dis voilà c'est ça
devait se passer comme ça depuis que
c'est le sport il ya des hauts et des
bas il faut faire avec championnats du
monde à suivre donc en février et
notamment sur l'antenne de téléphiles
solidarité mettre son entreprise au
service des plus démunis pendant une
journée c'est l'action qui vient d'être
mené par une responsable dans le salon
d'esthétique à rambouillet elle est
allée travailler gratuitement dans les
locaux du secours catholique
williams elles étaient présents manucure
soins du visage ou coiffure pendant une
journée six amis tech a fermé son salon
d'esthétique pour offrir ses services
gratuitement dans les locaux du secours
catholique
alors on a fonctionné avec vous ce
rendez vous donc les personnes qui
souhaitent s'inscrire peuvent s'inscrire
nous on a décidé d'être là toute la
journée donc qu'il y ait des rendez-vous
coupat on sera ouvert quel que soit le
motif de la personne ait baha pourra
pousser la porte et à sera accueilli les
bras ouverts
une initiative accueillie à bras ouverts
les gens ont répondu présent et selon
les propres mots des 6èmes voir des
sourires sincères sur tous les visages
ça ça n'a pas de prix
je pense que ça leur fait vraiment
plaisir il ya des gens qui s'épient le
même il ya des gens qui font leurs
couleurs eux mêmes il ya des gens qui
coupent leurs cheveux eux-mêmes s'ils
nous ont dit parce qu'ils sont pas
effectivement les moyens de se faire
beau au jour d'aujourd'hui ils ont juste
les moyens pour survivre
déjà vue classique certains sont même un
peu perdu car pour eux c'est une
première mais aujourd'hui l'important
c'est d'être bien dans sa peau je veux
que c'est bien c'est sympa puisque pas
tout le monde a les moyens de se payer
sa mise en pratique
c'est une initiative qu'on trouve très
intéressante et qui permet d'ajouter un
peu plus de lien social entre les
personnes que nous recevons
pour nous c'est très riche parce que les
personnes qui viennent là se retrouvant
entre eux dans les murs qu'ils
connaissent mois sont un peu chez elle
une vingtaine de personnes a profité de
cette journée pour siham pas question de
s'arrêter là elle compte bien réitérer
l'opération mais espère avant tout
inspiré ses confrères un salon dédié au
bien-être c'est ce que proposait
dimanche dernier la maison des
associations de voisins-le-bretonneux
art de vivre épanouissement personnel au
programme en présence de sophrologue ou
encore de naturopathe le reportage de
mélanie poquet d'elodie mois
le tchi kong pratiques chinoises pour
retrouver un équilibre visant
l'épanouissement individuel le bien-être
ou l'entretien de la santé à travers
posture corporelle exercices de
respiration le tchi kong permet de
renforcer le corps est délié les membres
en n'étant plus disponible à soi même on
va déjà être beaucoup moins stressé on
va être plus posé et on va pouvoir
rentrer en lien avec les autres
l'enseignement du tchi kong c'est
vraiment renseigné pour que les gens
deviennent autonomes et fasse tout un
tas de petites pratiques chez eux mais
que leur quotidien deviennent un tchi
kong c'est à dire qu'en fait rien que
dans la posture verticale ou à 6 ils
vont déjà être dans le tchi kong
outre le tchi kong l'association
organisatrice proposé de découvrir
diverses techniques de relaxation et de
bien-être
les saint-quentinois ont ainsi pu
échanger autour de la sophrologie
l'art thérapie et diverses techniques de
massage l'idée première c'était que de
faire profiter les personnes qui
pouvaient pas venir nous voir le soir
donc on a dit le juge dans la journée
les jeunes mamans qui ont des enfants ne
peuvent pas venir le soir les personnes
plus âgées ne veulent pas sortir le soir
donc proposer dans la journée c'était
plus facile pour elle en ce moment on a
besoin de se recentrer sur soi et d'être
bien pour être bien avec les autres à se
recentrer sur soi et être moins stressé
à chacun de trouver la formule qui
marche
de quoi repartir du bon pied dans un
instant sur tv fil 78 je vous retrouve
pour le 7-8 politique consacrée cette
semaine exclusivement à l'avenir de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines les nouvelles frontières se
dessine nous en parlerons avec les
principaux acteurs de ce dossier très
bonne soirée
ce